the game of chess is played on a chess
board just like you see before you
with the pieces set up just as they are
now so what exactly does it mean to play
a game of Fischer random well we
randomized the pieces now Fischer random
is also called chess960 why is that
chess960 refers to the fact that when
you rebuild the pieces on the first rank
randomly you have 960 possible different
positions now why is it even called
Fischer random then why not just
chess960 well Bobby Fischer was the
world champion and probably the most
famous advocate for the game in the
1970s he was known for playing it and
coffee houses with friends forcing them
to dive into his new favorite variation
of the game of chess and in the 1990s it
was officially acknowledged in Buenos
Aires in 1996 that Bobby Fischer really
was the ambassador for the game and
hence given a namesake to follow Fischer
random chess chess 960 regardless of
whatever it's called we have a lot to
learn about what it takes to not just
play the game but play it well and in
this video we're gonna dive into not
just the rules but also the tips you
need to start playing chess 960 games
and winning them right away let's jump
in
now one of the trickiest aspects and
perhaps the only truly different rules
that exist in Fischer random as compared
to classical chess are the rules to
castling to simplify that we've cleared
the board of all the pieces to leave us
with only the King for each side and a
pair of Brooks one of the rules that
formalize itself under the advice of
Bobby Fischer was that moving forward
the king would always need to start
between the two rooks this ensures the
ability that you will always have the
option of castling to either side of the
board so how does castling work well to
start let's say that if white wanted to
Castle kingside
you could drag the King to the g1 Square
and literally switch places with the
white rook
if black wanted to Castle queenside
nothing about the rooks position would
change but the black King would find
itself in the end on the square c8
let's take a look at it
here we see the finished version of what
it would be if Whitehead castled King
side and if black had Castle queenside
in our next board we're gonna learn how
that process is followed in an online
chess game if you want to castle all you
have to do is pick up your King and drag
it either directly on top of the square
where the rook stands or you can go even
further all the way to the knight let's
first see what happens when we drag our
King on top of the rook and let them
swap places for black to castle once
again it would be the same thing black
could drag his King on top of the rook
or all the way on top of the night and
after doing so the king and rook will
switch places one of the key things to
note about this example where both sides
have castled is that even though the
Queen's and the Knights officially stand
on squares that in classical chess would
be in the way of the king and the rook
and Fischer random chess as long as the
pieces do not obstruct the final landing
places of a completed castle it does not
prevent castling so as you see the fact
that the knight is on H 1 and the Queen
is on e 1 that does not in theory
prevent the king and rook from swapping
places to complete a traditional castle
and the same is here
for the black queen and the Black Knight
the position of those two pieces do not
prevent black from castling because once
again they do not obstruct the final
resting place of a completed castle
position now that we've seen an example
of the pieces randomly shuffled along
the 1st and 8th rank let's take a look
at a real life game plucked from what
was considered by many to be the first
ever unofficial Fisher of random World
Chess Championship match this took place
in February 2018 in Oslo Norway between
Hikaru Nakamura and Magnus Carlsen
now as we dive into this game what I
want to highlight is that just because
the pieces are randomly set up that
doesn't mean that the goals have
suddenly become random here we see two
of the best players in the world follow
the principles to start out with a mood
that attacks the center and opens a
piece directly assaulting what is
supposed to be the most critical areas
of the board black castles and white
choosers do the same despite the fact
that the king and rook are only
switching one square over note that both
Carlson and Nakamura stressed the need
for their looks to be connected working
well with their Queen to potentially
assault the center these are classical
chess principles we all know and follow
and that is to develop coordinate and
then ultimately fight for the most
critical areas of the board those being
the center over the next few moves both
sides did exactly that in a game that
saw an event you will draw I would argue
because both sides followed chess
principles to start their Fischer random
chess game and fought equally for the
center for many moves to come while our
next game wasn't plucked from an
unofficial official random World Chess
Championship match it was a battle that
took place between two very strong
grandmasters in st. Louis in this
chess960 position we had reigning US
Champion at the time Sam Shanklin
playing the white pieces and French
number one Maxime ba Sheila grab a in
black and this position Maxime chose to
follow suit ala Carlson and Nakamura
were despite the odd seeming switch of
just a single square of the black king
and rook he chose this coordination of
the rooks as a critical piece for his
middle game attack essentially
coordinating his heavy pieces for the
middle game rather than follow suit
however Sam Shanklin decided to play the
move h4 at the expense of his own Kings
position he's trying to launch a flank
attack it makes sense when you consider
that the two bishops are assaulting the
black King however as we've been
highlighting just because the pieces are
shuffled that doesn't mean our
principles have to go out the window
with it and Maxime ba Sheila Grove shows
Sam Shanklin that can
trolling the center and coordinating
your King in a classical fashion would
have been a much better idea we're gonna
jump ahead a few moments just show that
despite the fact that Sam was able to
expose Maxim's King ultimately the
coordination of the Brooks in the center
and white sock or King would tell the
story as to who really had a better
middlegame attack Maxine played the move
Knight to c4 exclam with devastating
intentions when Sam played Knight to d4
he missed the coming combination and the
brilliant finish that MVL put on here to
end this game in just a few moves Knight
to III check sacrificing the knight in
order to force open the F file
Sam tried to avoid it by taking with the
bishop and said of the pawn but after f
takes with the threat of rook takes F to
checkmate in one
Sam was forced to play the move Knight
f3 and he missed Maxim's next move which
comes with devastating effects a queen
sacrifice he takes F to double exclam of
the atch after Knight takes e5 Bishop h4
we see the idea black doesn't intend to
just get pieces for the Queen he intends
to go Bob Barker and get the full thing
the King is on the line with threats
like f takes a 1 double check and mate
white played the move g3 in order to
postpone that fate but bishop h3 check
forcing rook g2 and then Bishop takes g3
renewing the idea of capturing on e 1
was enough for Sam to resign note that a
move like Knight f3 trying to close the
F file once again fails to just renegade
awesomeness by Maxime taking a three and
then taking a one is one way that this
game would have still ended in a forced
checkmate now that we've seen a couple
of real game examples where very strong
grandmasters followed classical chess
principles like get your king safe get
your pieces coordinated early and attack
the center we should feel more prepared
to go play official random game and
confident that the tools we've developed
to play well in classical chess can help
us win chess960 games - in our last
example before we bring this video to a
close we wanted to show you a very very
funny position that highlights the
awkward position of the black king who
didn't get himself out of the center in
time and perhaps forgot his opponents
ability to castle in this position
rather than fix the problem of the king
being awkwardly placed on an open line
in the center black brought the bishop
to a square that attacked the white rook
on f1 only to find white shocked him by
castling right in the middle of the
board white brings the King just as we
learned right on top of the rook on c1
and in doing so we see the king and rook
switch places and white immediately
deliver a devastating check
black postponed the checkmate as long as
he could with the move Bishop to d3 rook
takes d3 but ultimately found his end on
the e-file where we see a very awkward
rather humorous example where a castles
in a game of Fisher random chess leads
to a forced checkmate now that you know
all the rules to how to play Fisher
random and of course you're excited to
deliver your own checkmate by castles in
the middle of the board today head over
to chefs calm select the play tab at the
chess comm live arena find the 960
option in the drop down rather than
standard chess choose your time control
click play and away you go
of course if you're interested in
playing in a chess960 tournament we have
them going all the time under our
tournaments tab and you can find them
anywhere you see the little chess960
icon ready for you to get started right
away well we know this video may have
brought some new ideas your way the
earliest versions of shuffle chests
actually date back as far as the 1790s
and fidei acknowledged chess960 as a
variant to their great game in 2008 then
they announced their support of the
first ever Fisher random a World Chess
Championship in April 2019 and if you
don't believe me look at these tweets by
some great young players who all agree
that Fisher random or chess960 may be
the future of our great game so get
started and consider playing chess 960
or fish a random chess today and we hope
to see you doing it on chess calm